[Music]
the search for sustainable development
becomes the search for an adequate mode
of civilization in the 21st century at
the center of the idea of sustainability
I think is an ethical imperative to pass
on an undiminished future to our
children well no one is smart enough or
can know enough to predict the future
so if prediction is not a possibility
then how can we make progress in
thinking about our options and thinking
about the future in an organized manner
and this is where scenario analysis
comes in
[Music]
when we discuss scenarios we talk about
three broad channels radiating out into
the future one we call conventional
worlds basically an evolutionary
sequence of events despite hiccups like
the current meltdown that the basic
paradigm and values persist into the
future the second channels Barbara's
ation which markets and policies are
unable to cope with the crises the chaos
and social disruption and the
environmental deterioration that is
induced by conventional world and you
have futures of catastrophic disruption
and the third we call great transitions
where people rise to the possibilities
to the promise of this planetary phase
with new values and new institutions and
steer and developing steers towards a
more fortunate form of civilization to
necessary conditions that must evolve to
reach a civilization worth living in
over the next ten years we will see a
wave of engagement and action of the
citizens of the world I think the what I
call for shorthand a global citizens
movement is the necessary condition the
necessary change agent for a turning
away from catastrophe away from the
abyss toward earth land this great
transition future I think that the
upsurge in civil society that we are
seeing now and have seen for the last 20
years is a glimpse of what could occur
but that civil society
permit is limited today by fragmentation
by lack of a shared vision of the
possible and I think this global
citizens movement is ready to be barred
I think it's latent I think it could be
brought to life so that is the first
area I think the secondaries is this
away from consumerism and individualism
and the domination of nature and war
towards questions of the quality of life
and the ecological sensibility and human
solidarity that would also be the second
pillar that would signal that a shift
towards a great transition is possible
[Music]
I think if we get to a this livable
future it will be because Humanity has
found a way to balance the paradigms of
global responsibilities with diversity
and pluralism in modes of culture and
development when we take our trips to
outer space and we look back we see an
integral blue planet you don't see
imaginary lines of states and so that
this globalism the sense of the earth as
a natural unit for a human organization
and identity in some ways more profound
than are the imaginary boundaries of of
nation-state when we look at the
question of value change that could
undergird this great transition I think
we have to look at the process of change
in in two arenas one in affluent
countries and one in developing
countries and affluent countries we're
already seeing the precursors the
questioning of the meaning of the good
life turning towards questions about the
quality of existence not just the
quantity of things as defining success
and well-being so that's one area is a
value change is in terms of what it is
to be a whole person in a fulfilled
person I think when we come to the
question of the developing world there's
an even more profound transition that we
can imagine to begin to define their own
agenda for development that there are
plural paths to modernity not a single
path and that their own paths can
leapfrog a lot of the mistakes that have
gone on in the industrialized world and
begin to come up with forms and models
of development that
build on local traditions and customs
and culture another area comes to the
question of the environment people I
think are coming to see that the
rapaciousness of the past must give way
to a sense of humanity's place in the
web of life and dependence on its health
sustainability and bounty so this is a
major almost Copernican shift in
awareness Copernicus taught us that we
didn't live at the center of the
universe but that we were on a planet
that revolved around the Sun well this
new Copernican revolution I think is
telling us that we are not at the center
of Earth we are part of the web of life
of this grand ecology and if we don't
take care to see our place within it
then we may go down with it
[Music]
I think there are three major areas that
we need to move down to begin this
transition and those areas I think are
understanding vision and action I think
we need to gain a better grasp of this
world we live in in this emergent global
system both as scientists and as
citizens we need to struggle to expand
our mental maps to traverse over space
to take into account a global panorama
the span over time to think over many
decades where people from all over the
world can find their place within the
broad umbrella that unifies their
various concerns into a broad-based
process of awareness building and
political change that can actually begin
to steer things in a fundamentally
different direction so when we do reach
our Time of Troubles which well could
come a time of systemic global crises
that there is the political space and
possibility for recovery more than
recovery for building and beginning a
new history
[Music]
you
[Music]